julie is with us in washington d.c hey
julie how are you
i'm good how are you dave good how can
we help
uh i'm calling today with a question
about
um using an inheritance that i received
to
either invest or pay off my mortgage and
i'm a long-time listener of the show and
i know that
you always say that you know if i'm
already investing 15
then i should go ahead and throw extra
money on the mortgage
and i guess two parts of this is
you know i still have about 430 000 on
the mortgage
but i think we're probably going to move
in the next two to three years
and so thinking about it you know the
inheritance is 150
000 so i can't completely pay off the
mortgage
and i'm concerned that i would earn more
you know investing that for two years
and getting a good return
rather than you know what the house
might appreciate in the two years before
we move and so i was hoping you could
better explain why you recommend
the mortgage route in this situation the
house is going to appreciate exactly the
same amount whether it has debt on it or
not
sure so you putting 150 on it doesn't
cause more appreciation
the only savings you would have would be
the interest rate on the that amount of
debt
uh whatever your mortgage interest rate
is and as compared to what you might
make on a mutual fund that might be
small
to your point to your concern i would
put it on the mortgage
anyway and the reason is
that i am going to have a paid off
mortgage whether it's selling this
property and moving the equity to
another property
but i'm going to have a paid off home as
a part of your financial plan
as soon as i possibly can because all of
the data
with all the millionaires that we work
with uh from the millionaire study that
hogan did
says that there's two primary things
that cause people to have their first
million dollar net worth
and first one to five million dollar net
worth and that is their 401k retirement
savings yes
and you're not going to put it in that
because it's payroll deduct
and um and a paid off home mortgage it
is
we did not find a single millionaire
out of 10 000 of them that we studied
that said i became wealthy because i
never paid off my home
and i used all of that money to invest
right right
all of them either had their homes paid
off
or were heading towards having their
homes paid off
they never once said oh i i would never
pay off my home because i always want to
invest
and one key thing she she said there
today was she thinks
so yeah so still put it on the mortgage
because yeah things may change
too if you don't if you do stay you can
pay off the mortgage if you don't stay
uh you know they're going to give you
that money at the closing when you sell
the house
exactly in the form of equity and come
back to you so you don't lose the money
what you are going to lose potentially
in the short term
is what you would have made in a mutual
fund versus
your mortgage interest rate which might
be
fifteen thousand bucks a year might be
2 000 bucks a year something like that
um
but i'm going with the data and the data
says
paid off home one step to being
millionaire
and i'm always going to move that
direction and so that keeps me right on
those baby
steps you can certainly do what you want
to do that's what i would do